Jason Bateman must have taken like the
energy drink at the beginning of this
year because he is making comedies so
fast even faster than the Smurfs is
making money and shouldn't the change-up
stars Jason Bateman and Ryan Reynolds
and it's a very basic plot that we have
seen quite often where two people who
are in different life situations somehow
magically switch bodies become the other
person had to live the other person's
life and causes lots of comedy and all
different types of things ensue however
we've never seen it really like this
this film explores a much different side
of that plot
Jason Bateman is a lawyer who is about
to hopefully get this partnership he's
looking for and Ryan Reynolds is a
struggling actor who really isn't doing
much of his life they both kind of
inexplicably wish for each other's lives
while peeing in one of those wish pools
we throw your coins in they wake up the
next day in jail there's bodies and
there's no point in me pointing out how
ludicrous that is because you know it's
just one of those comedies like liar
liar where something happens where you
know and you're just like wow that would
never happen obviously but it's
hilarious let's go with it
I actually really enjoyed the change of
one of the reasons I enjoyed it so much
was because of the chemistry between
Jason Bateman and Ryan Reynolds one of
the greatest things about these movies
where people switch bodies like that
when the actor is able to perfectly
embody the character of the person he
switched with that is always so
entertaining to watch it reminded me of
this film called face off which is not a
comedy at all but it was with Nicolas
Cage and John Travolta both of them when
they switched bodies it was so
entertaining to see them act like the
other actor and that is what we have
here we have Jason Bateman Brian realms
doing that and they have such excellent
chemistry for another they are like a
comedic tour-de-force in this movie it
just all flows out so naturally between
the two of them they have such a good
rapport with one another on film the
main difference between the average
body-switching comedy like what we've
seen before is this film is insane it is
absolutely outrageous the stuff cosine
is just like wow
just explores what happens when you come
home and suddenly you are with your
friend's wife also we have Leslie Mann
in the film and I feel like she over
acted in a few scenes she was really
kind of just going for it aloud with
this with some of the crying scenes she
has where she was trying to make it
funny they came up as a little bit much
but for the most part I enjoyed her
performance and I thought she was fine
Olivia Wilde is also in this movie and
she has a problem she is so beautiful
that when she is on screen it's like the
frame cannot contain it
the frame is too good-looking when it's
a close-up of her she is so pretty that
when she is on screen it's like you
cannot even focus see what I mean I mean
are you even looking at me right now or
are you looking over there I mean it's
impossible you have to acknowledge this
she's very good in the film she's very
funny I said this about Cowboys and
Aliens she's not one of those actresses
where you're just like why she's so good
they can act she's a good actress
some of the issues I had with the phone
or that it seemed too long I'm not
entirely sure how long it was but I do
remember that about 15 to 20 minutes
before it ended I was thinking it should
end right around now also the film jumps
very abruptly between absolute insane
humor and more heartfelt scenes the
tonal shifts were off at times Alan
Arkin is also in the film and his
character didn't really seem to fit I
understand why he needed to be there for
the story but it seems like his
character could easily have been deleted
from the film and the film wouldn't have
lost anything in fact it might have
actually flowed better movie has flaws
of course but from a straightforward
comedy standpoint it's insane it
explores various aspects of what might
happen if you switch bodies with one of
your friends that a lot of people don't
really think about I didn't like it
quite as much as Horrible Bosses or
bridesmaids but I still had a lot of fun
with this movie and I kind of fought
with my rating and when I was driving
home but I'm gonna give the change-up
three and a half out of four stars
because honestly I felt for these
characters I related to them and I
wanted things to work out for them and I
laughed a lot Ryan Reynolds is hilarious
in a Jason Bateman's funny in if they
both work off each other really well and
I think it's definitely good comedy
especially if you're fans of either
those actors you should definitely check
it out please stop looking
the Olivia Wilde picture and try to
focus on me come on you guys
come on try to try to tone it down what
are you guys doing I'm just kidding
she's really hot so every liked this
review subscribe to my channel and get
steppen eyes